all right art
away from originally where'd you grow up
uh Columbus Georgia
and tell me about how you grew up you
had Mom and Dad good childhood uh Mom
and Dad yeah
military military
how far are you in school
uh graduated from Columbus College
what'd you want to do with your life
biologists biologists what did you do it
it's your life not a fish buyer
where at
all over the world
Alaska Australia Fiji
New Zealand
where have you lived most of your life
uh in Alaska basically oh really
what city
Homer and Anchorage as a fish buyer yes
and married kids stuff like that I have
two kids
exalt kids
and you still married
I'm sorry are you still married no
divorce
and uh you you tell me you like to come
to Thailand
I'm going to time for
over 30 years now 30 years
well since 1981 actually yeah
a lot of a lot of fun things to do here
in Bangkok
definitely elsewhere especially
but it's changed it's really changing
has it changed
coach Matt used to be one of my favorite
places but now I I just got back from
there it's just It's just sad what
they've done to it
and I found you tonight in one of the
gentlemen's clubs a [__] Club
is is [__] ladyboys are your thing or
is that just something you just stumbled
into
I just stumbled into it basically yeah
this is accident
are the uh
The Men's Clubs here like we're at Nana
Plaza that's where I found you although
it's something you frequent when you
come here I'm sorry are the are the
Men's Clubs here in Bangkok something
you you you visit every time you're here
uh no actually I don't I just I go to
the Hard Rock Cafe
in Bangkok have a good time and uh
and hang out on Coach Chang there's a
club called uh
good lord I can't think of it
I don't know I hang out at this club
called coaching it's a
it's a great Club a lot of Hardcore rock
and roll AC DC
and then at work the Beatles the stones
all good good just good music
but but you will frequent the The Men's
Clubs the girls that are available here
I'm sorry you will you will hire some of
the girls that are here in in Bangkok at
the clubs I
I've only had like two girls that I know
of one in Bangkok one in uh
in coaching oh really
oh [__] I should have asked you this
before I brought you over I was kind of
looking for somebody who's like who
really
frequents these clubs
well I I must admit I freak I freak him
a lot I actually wanted when I let on to
be
but you say you've only done it twice
only been with hookers
from these clubs twice yeah yeah but I
frequented the shark entire Club
a bunch of times and uh insomnia Club
and uh good Lord
I can't think of the other clubs I have
visited but yeah
but these These are girls that you'll
pay for your time for their time
I'm assuming that I paid for a lot of
girls
yeah
from Seattle to
to to Florida to
be Lord
the girls here in Thailand are beautiful
the girls in these clubs are beautiful
oh God yeah yeah I love I love Thai
women they're gorgeous
Cambodian women are just as equal as
gorgeous a lot of guys seem to be uh
hanging out here in this club in this
Plaza just just for that
I bet you they come here just for that
reason alone
yeah in fact I traveled to
uh
uh Bangkok and
and Tom pins quite a bit is it town
called certain uh signalville in
Cambodia it has those outrageous
gorgeous girls in the world
they're just beautiful and they're if
you're American you speak the language
they just they don't charge it they just
love to be an American
it's great it's just absolutely one of
the funnest times I've had my life
the same thing with China Beach in
Vietnam girls are beautiful they don't
they just love Americans and they don't
want a dime if you take them out to
dinner or a movie that they're thrilled
to death
why is it that the Vietnam people like
Americans so much I have no idea after
what we did that country I have no idea
but they still do how old are you
I'm 72. 72 did you fight in Vietnam yes
I did
is that where you first discovered this
part of the world
yeah I'm not real proud of what I did
over there in fact I'm very sad about it
I don't think about it pretty much
pretty much yeah
I heard it explained that Vietnam people
Vietnam as a countries had so many wars
that the one with the US was just one of
many
yeah they love the U.S what they really
hate Russians than the Chinese they just
can't stand them
what they've done to our country is this
outrageous It's just sad
disgusting frankly
do you think do you think prostitution
should be something that's legal
I'm sorry do you think prostitution
should be legalized let's be legalized
every country in the world New Zealand
Australia has a great
uh they make a shitload of money off the
prosecution especially in Auckland New
Zealand
and Cairns Australia is perfectly legal
it's just it blows my mind the United
States
except for Nevada
and is the only place you could you know
have sex for for money you know
you think
humans are meant to be monogamous no I
don't think that
I could never be one partner is that
what ended your marriage
uh no my end of my marriage is my uh
I travel all the world and I was never
home and and I did a lot of cocaine
and last place for another marriage
right
let's not be at home and doing drugs
so when you when you pick up these girls
whether it's in
Vietnam or or here in Thailand in
Bangkok you you take them back to your
hotel you have some fun you pay them and
they're out of your life is either I
they have a place to stay or I go to a
hotel room or it it's uh
it's kind of up in the air it's just
it's
it's uh mostly the hotel room
and uh yeah
not pretty much it
and on the beach as well
do any of these girls you ever get
attached to any of these girls that you
see I'm sorry do you ever get attached
to any of these girls and you'll come
back and visit them over and over again
there's a couple that I come back to see
but yeah yeah
are you enjoying this this part of your
life where you're you're no longer
working and you're free having the best
time of my life right now
I travel the world I just you know have
a fun time and I just uh
I'm just having a good time
after all that's what life's about if
you know to have a fun time in life
what do you think of [__] bar that I
found you in
they're interesting that's for sure
they're beautiful
they're absolutely gorgeous you know I
think they might even be more beautiful
than the regular girls they are they are
they are absolutely
stunningly beautiful
boyfriend named Pond and she's just
gorgeous as hell
a friend of mine salt of the earth is a
sweet sweet person general just caring
and just loving
and uh yeah I love her with all my heart
I love well Hammer but
we've never had sex but
yeah but
she's something else
yeah I've interviewed a bunch
of them this week and I have a hard hard
time believing that these are
originally male
I know I I'm the same way they're
absolutely gorgeous they're they're just
and they're they're their their heart's
in the right place which makes it even
more amazing yeah there's no drugs
there's no no drugs no drugs you know I
love it you know they just want to be
girls
crazy world that we live in
a lot of them are just doing this just
to support their families
exactly you know when when you when when
an average time
peasant makes 500 Baht a month you know
it's really hard to live on
and that's what these guys in the Hills
The Hills right people make about 500
500 Baht a month which is like nothing
and they actually you know
these pimps from Bangkok or wherever
else in the world they come over they
they bother doors for like 10 000 Baht
for
they put them to work in these brothels
and it's just it's a pretty sad
situation really
humans are the same everywhere we go it
seems
yeah I'm you know I can't I'm
you know I've bought
I must say about
a lot of Thai girls for 500 Baht from
Chiang Mai to Chiang Rai to
Phuket to Bangkok and
not real problem I did
it hurts me every day
I'll move that again that's for sure
do you have any regrets in your life
oh yeah
Vietnam is a regret
did you enlist or got drafted
I enlisted
and I was a big stupid mistake well
unless because this but my best friend
who was killed of Vietnam
uh
it's a long story but uh yeah
I was because of him
what are your fears now at this age this
stage of your life
oh
I don't really have any fears you know I
just I just want my son and my daughter
to grow up to be
to have a happy life and uh
in my ex my two Ex-Wives to be you know
happy as well and
very successful
but you're happy with your life and what
you how you spent it I'm sorry you're
happy with your life and how you spent
it oh yeah totally what you did your
work and things like that yeah I have no
complaints
you must have some fun stories of all
your trips here 30 trips to okay you
must have some interesting stories
coming to Bangkok for 30 years
yeah I got some crazy stories that's for
sure
can you share one of them
oh
one time I was
I was in this bar this restaurant and uh
Patty it and they had I was I was on a I
was fasted for like two weeks I was on a
juice fast
and I came off the fast and I walked in
this restaurant and said that that had a
sign that said uh special mushroom
omelets for sale
and I ate not one but two of them this
guy goes you must really want to get out
there what do you talk about those are
suicide mushroom omelets you to say
and I said you're kidding about two
hours later I was out there I was [__]
up beyond belief the restaurant was
serving psilocybin mushrooms I was so
screwed up I went to the Cop Shop said
somebody trying to kill me yes what did
I eat I said I said most wanted this cop
just laughed and he says you just need
to take a walk on the beach and just
mellow out because nothing we can do for
you this is a cop said that they could
have locked me up but they didn't
that was a strange time
all right what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life
oh
[Music]
to respect others
and their feelings and their beliefs
and to treat everybody individually as a
kind person
that's right
all right Arthur thank you so much for
sharing your story I'm sorry thank you
so much for sharing your story
sure and I wish you best of luck out
there Have fun wherever you end up
tonight
yes I appreciate that all right thank
you
so some of the
women the lady boys in the in these
clubs are spectacularly gorgeous as we
talked about
have are you there out of curiosity is
it I mean what what brought you into
that club
uh
curiosity more than anything
have you ever had encounters with the
ladyboys I'm sorry have you ever had an
any encounters with the lady where
you've hired a [__] uh conference uh
have you ever hired a [__]
I must say yes I have
and was it a pleasurable experience I
mean it's different obviously it was
there's some different equipment it was
quite it was quite pleasurable to be
honest with you I can't lie about that
it was very pleasurable yeah I mean I
look at some of these women there there
is attractive it was
it was great it was absolutely one of
the highlights of my life to be honest
with you really
we went back to the room and
we took our clothes off and he goes
and I go holy [__] you're a [__] he
goes I thought you knew I said no I
didn't have any clues well you've ever
been a [__] before I said no but my
curiosity got the best of me and
we end up having sex
it was one of the
best sex experience of my life to be
honest with you no it's no [__] one
of the questions I've asked these ladies
is because they're
born male
part of them is male they think male
they maybe understand what a man enjoys
and likes better than a female exactly
exactly
it threw me for a loop but it was one of
the best times my whole life that's for
sure no [__] about it
it was wild
yeah I I
the world has changed hasn't it yes it
is
it got me
kind of
things about all sexuality my answer am
I I I'm just bi-curious is all
well I think you and I come from a
generation where that was forbidden you
never would admit it never talk about it
and now things are the life life is
different where people are proud of it
and they're this good friend of mine got
his ass beat to hell because he had an
affair with another guy in high school
and I just so shocked that this friend
of mine got his asking for being
bisexual bicurious you know yeah some
people are really uptight about that it
really sucks
but you had a good time and enjoyed your
your date with a [__]
I must say it was definitely fun and
you've been back for more with other
ones
only
twice yeah
nobody I saw you hanging out there
tonight if you're hanging out in a
barber shop you're gonna get your hair
cut
exactly well I was I don't know what I
was doing there to be honest with you
I do
yeah well I was going to three other
ladyboys that have sex with tonight
that's no [__]
I ain't gonna lie anymore
and I found this gorgeous [__] that
was just
really sweet and uh
I don't know what happened I just really
don't so we just kind of
faded apart yeah
mainly because I was too drunk and he
didn't want to have to do anything yeah
yeah but there's a there's a million of
them there's so many of them what's that
there's so many to choose from oh there
is
they're everywhere you know Thailand
you can't get away from them
no I had
a [__] experiencing coaching on the
beach one time
where we had this insane sex on the
beach in Koh Chang
and white sand beach
there was nobody around and we just had
great sex
not hurting anybody
no
and we kissed and we parted aways and
last as I saw her saw her of him anyway
they're definitely
there's nobody like him period
they're so beautiful and so sincere and
so honest you know the thing about the
the
most of them don't lie you know they're
just they're just so open-minded and
it's refreshing to meet somebody like
that no drugs no drugs no drugs they're
not on drugs like they are like I do a
lot of interviews with transgenders in
Los Angeles and they're all high as a
kite
here the lady boys here don't do drugs I
I only met one [__] that I
I didn't pick it up I was partying with
it with him and uh
just born in Bangkok I don't know where
it was but you know he was
hitting a pipe of of ice you know every
15 minutes I go this is [__] I end
up leaving
and I'll be around them no but here they
seem mentally healthy they're not on
drugs they're supporting their families
and it's great you know there's they're
absolutely so genuine
it's it's just amazingly refreshing is
what it is
and they're just absolutely
they're special people
I suppose I'd probably marry one if I
found the right one yeah
all right Art thank you so much for
sharing your story
I'm glad I could I wish you all the luck
in the world out there have some fun in
the club tonight I surely will all right
thanks